what do you make of elon musk you have
spoken about him a bit you might have
struck with admiration
that's what i make now when i was
actually this idea i always think of
that as a primary
well it's all it's like do you find this
comedian funny it's like well i laugh at
him
you know what i mean it's not
propositional again
and so
i would there are things i would like to
ask
mr musk about
the mars venture i don't know what he's
up to there it strikes me as absurd in
the most fundamental sense because i
think well it'd be easier just to build
an outpost in the antarctica or in the
desert well how much of the human
endeavor is absurd well
that's what did nietzsche say great men
are seldom credited with their stupidity
who the hell knows what musk is up to i
mean obviously he's building rockets now
he's motivated because he wants to build
a
a platform for life on mars is that a
good idea
who am i to say he's he's building the
rockets man but i'd like to ask him
about it i i would like to see that
conversation i do think
that
having talked to him quite a bit offline
i think these
several of his ideas like mars like
humans becoming a multi-planetary
species could be
one of the things that human
civilization looks back at as
duh
i can't believe he's one of the few
people that was really pushing this idea
because it's the obvious
thing for for society for life to
survive yeah well it isn't obvious to me
that i'm in any position to evaluate
elon musk like i would like to talk to
him and find out what he's up to and why
but
i mean he's an impossible person what
he's done is impossible all of it
it's like he built an electric car that
works now does it work completely and
will it replace gas cars or should it i
don't know but
if we're going to build electric cars he
seems to be the best at that by a lot
and he more or less did that people carp
about him but he more or less did that
by himself i know he's very good at
distributing responsibility and all of
that but he's the spearhead and then
that was pretty hard and then he built a
rocket
at like one tenth the price of nasa
rockets and then he shot his car out
into space
that's pretty hard
and then he's building this boring
company more or less as a
what would you call it
it's sort of it's this whimsical joke in
some sense but it's not a joke
he's amazing and you're a link delving
into the uh the depths of the mind and
starlink it's like
go elon as far as i'm concerned and then
you know he puts his finger on things so
oddly
the prop the problem is under population
it's like i think so too i think it's a
terrible problem that we're
the west for example is no longer
at
replacement with regard to birth rate it
means we've abandoned the virgin and the
child in a most fundamental sense it's a
bloody catastrophe and musk he sees it
clear as can be it's like wow and where
everyone else is running around going oh
there's too many people it's like
nope
got that not only see i've learned that
there are falsehoods and lies and there
are anti-truths
and an anti-truth is something that's so
preposterous that you couldn't
you couldn't make a claim that's more
opposite to the truth
and the claim that there are too many
people on the planet is an anti-truth
so you know people say well you have to
accept limits to growth and etc it's
like
i have to accept the limits that you're
going to impose on me because you're
frightened of the future
that's your theory is it
okay
you